hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
measuring molecular interactions
by multi-wavelength analytical
ultracentrifugation
my name is akash bhattacharya and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by beckmann culture life
sciences
the views expressed in this webinar are
those of the speaker
and not of beckman cultural life
sciences for more information
on beckmann coulter please visit
www.beckman.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
click on the supports tab found at the
top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem
by clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr boris demler
professor and canada 150 research chair
for biophysics
at the uni at the department of
chemistry and biochemistry
at the university of lethbridge in
alberta canada
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr daimler you may now begin your
presentation
welcome everybody i'm bernie stimula and
i'm broadcasting today
from the university of lethbridge and
beautiful southern alberta
i will be discussing multi-wavelength
analytical ultracentrifugation
a new method for studying heterogeneous
systems
and molecular interactions
analytical ultracentrifugation or auc
for short
as a time-honored technique which was
invented in the 1920s by swedish
physicist
t swedberg swedberg
was awarded the nobel prize in chemistry
for his work on dispersed systems
and the invention of the analytical
ultracentrifuge that was in 1926.
if you ever visit the university of
uppsala in sweden where you worked
uh stop by and visit his old laboratory
which is now a museum
here you will be able to find the
original instrument used by swedberg for
his pioneering work
i i was there and visited it and took
those two pictures you see here
sometimes i wonder if swedberg would
have imagined the staying power and the
importance of this technique
and how important it would be today
almost 100 years later
for many studies nowadays auc is
considered the
gold standard characterization tool and
with modern instruments available today
this
is true now more than ever
so what can we learn from analytical
ultracentrifugation
i'm going to give you some background
here for those people who are not
familiar with auc
so we're on the same page in
sedimentation velocity experiments which
is the prime
type of experiment performed with
analytical ultracentrifugation
uh you measure the sedimentation and the
diffusion coefficient and the partial
concentration
of an analyte in a solution
if you perform what's called a density
matching experiment
you can also access the partial specific
volume of the analyte
and from all this information together
we can then learn
about molecule size molar mass
anisotropy and density
some people call it shape i like to call
it nsotropy because
auc really can't tell apart different
shapes all it can tell apart
is the globularity or how extended the
molecule is and we'll call it anisotropy
it's a
little bit more precise so molecules can
be studied
in a physiological environment which is
one of the big strengths of auc you put
your molecules in an
environment that replicates the
conditions inside of a cell
and the solution conditions can then be
adjusted
where you can modulate the concentration
of the analyte
maybe the effect of the ph by changing
that uh you can
test the ionic strength or the type of
buffer
that you used for the purification to
see if your molecule is stable in a
buffer
you can add ligands and see what it does
to your molecule and you can
even check what happens if you change
the oxidation state of the solution
by adding a reductant or you can change
the temperature and many other things
you have a very large size range
that you can access with analytical
ultracentrifugation because
you can vary the speed of the instrument
and measure very very small molecules at
very high speed
such as even things like solid ions
would move
at very high speed while on
at a slower speed you could then measure
particles as large as a
as a virus you can also access dynamics
where you measure the oligomerization
state of reversible sulfur
heteroassociations
where you can follow the binding of
ligands
and measure equilibrium constants the kd
and even slow kinetics you can do a
composition analysis
where you can take a mixture of
molecules
or an unknown molecule that's dissolved
in a solution
and you find out what is the number of
components in there
what are their partial concentrations in
each component's molecular weight and
enos entropy
you can do a conformational analysis
conformational analysis where you
follow the folding or the melting of
biopolymers
and you can check how
whether a molecule is intrinsically
disordered
extended or whether it's well folded and
you can also change the solution
properties and see
how that affects the conformational
change that the molecule might be
experiencing
it's also an excellent method for
characterizing any molecule or molecular
interaction in the solution environment
you don't need um a lot of material only
about a half a mil per sample
and you can measure up to 16 samples in
a single run
so it's i wouldn't say high throughput
but it's it's
fairly good throughput and the analysis
and this is very important is based on
first principles that is
all the transport that occurs inside of
the ultracentrifuge
um is well understood
how it works and so we can model this
with differential equations
solve the equations and then simply fit
the data to the equations
uh and get the right answer provided the
instrument is well calibrated
and so there are no external standards
required you don't need any reference
materials in order to see on what your
molecule is doing
so a little background about the
instrumentation
so you need a rotor uh these are made
out of titanium
and they either have four or eight holes
and the full
rotor can spin up to 60 000 rpm so
that's almost between 1 000 g
at the bottom of the cell and in the
holes you put your samples
samples are contained in a housing that
gets capped at the top and the bottom by
a sapphire window
and you can shine light through it so
here's the top view of one of those
cells and you can see that has two
compartments both of them are sector
shape that's where the sample goes
and if you blow up a sector you can see
that the solution
column in there has a vertical meniscus
because all the material gets pressed
against the wall so you have a vertical
meniscus
and above it you have a little air
pocket and
inside of it you have a concentration
gradient as the material sediments
towards the bottom of the cell
and piles up there to measure that
um you shine light of a selected
wavelength
through the sample and you then
watch the absorbance that you can record
below the sample
of how much light actually passes
through and the absorbance then is
proportional to the concentration at
every point in the cell
you make multiple recordings over time
and you get
then a full sedimentation velocity
experiment which has many scans
and each scan as a recording at
a different time point
so here's a simulation of this you
accelerate the rotor the boundary starts
moving
and it starts piling up at the bottom
where it on creates a very steep
concentration gradient
that causes it to diffuse back into the
cell against the sedimenting
sedimentation force so all those scans
get recorded
and then fitted to a
equation uh it's called the lamb
equation it's a partial differential
equation
and what it tells you is how the
concentration changes
over time at every point in the cell
or every radius in the cell and it
um describes the both the sedimentation
and the diffusion transport
and you can see these two terms circled
here in blue and
in red so this one is the sedimentation
term it'll give you the sedimentation
coefficient
and the diffusion coefficient from this
term and you fit this
on and to your experimental data and you
obtain those two parameters
as well as the concentration for each
particle
this lamb equation then can be solved by
the finite element method
and it's described in this reference
right here
this is a single wavelength experiment
and
what you can obtain from such an
experiment as
maybe a molar mass distribution as a
function of n
is entropy as shown here where each
solute
in your mixture will represent another
peak
and the peaks have different heights
according to the relative concentration
of each
uh material you can also show it here in
this
pseudo 3d plot where the color intensity
reflects the height of the peak
and a faint particle will not have a lot
of material in it
and then on after you go through all the
analysis you
then have the partial concentration of
each solute sedimentation and diffusion
coefficient
and uh perhaps the partial specific
volume if you did a
density matching experiment and you
obtain the molar mass
if there are interactions between these
molecules you can
obtain the kd or even the alpha rate if
the kinetics are slow
as well as the nsrp
so let's talk about multi-wavelength so
everything i've showed you so far
refers to a
single wavelength being measured so you
dial in
a particular wavelengths and you watch
for the absorbance
that is recorded on when that single
wavelength slide that monochromatic
light passes through the sample
but it gets interesting when you measure
the same sample at multiple wavelengths
because then you will be able to also
observe the spectral information that is
contained in your sample
in case the molecules that are there
have different absorbance spectra
and this is what we're capitalizing on
this was described
in this methods and enzymology paper
here from
2015 um and
um it was work done in collaboration
with my colleague professor hammut
kirfin at the university of
constance in germany he invented this
on this detector here this
multi-wavelength detector
that can record on up to 1024
wavelengths
in uh in a single scan
so you can scan your cell and instead of
getting a single wavelengths you get
1024 wavelengths
or the observance at 1024 wavelengths
you can do something very similar with
this instrument
on the new optima auc which
um not only um
well it cannot collect all of the
wavelengths all at the same time
it has to scan them one after another in
a sequential fashion
but on by doing that it still can obtain
all of the multi-wavelength information
of
that may be contained in your sample so
the good thing then is that for the
first time by doing
um a multi-wavelength analysis you can
achieve spectral separation between
the chemical absorbance properties of
your molecules
in addition to the hydrodynamic
separation of the different size species
and then both dimensions can be analyzed
and utilized to interpret the underlying
system properties
so here you see a typical
multi-wavelength experiment
and this experiment then shows
on basically the absorbance
properties in this dimension and then
here the traditional hydrodynamic
dimension
which shows how the boundary moves in
in the in the radial domain here's the
meniscus
and um by looking at these two pictures
you can tell already that we're looking
at two different chemicals here
because they have different absorbance
patterns here we have an absorbance at
280 a peak at 280 so this is most likely
a protein
and it goes up here at 250 240 it goes
back
up and here we look at the observance of
a dna molecule which has a peak at 260.
here's the movie of the same process so
you can see
how different boundaries move at
different rates
and on what we can then do
is take a particular slice
at one radial position or at any radial
position here
for example right here and what we get
is the wavelength scan at this
particular
position because here we have all the
wavelengths
and so this is becomes wavelengths
scan off the chemical or the analyte
that is sedimenting at this position in
the cell
so what can we do with this information
if you
have for example a mixture out of
protein
and dna then these would be the
absorbances that you would see
so in this case we have a protein called
bsa or boron serum albumin
and a dna molecule in this case it's a
it's a digest of a plasmid
the dna is shown in red and the protein
molecule is shown in purple here
if you were to take these two molecules
and you would mix them together
at different ratios you would get on
scans in between here
so for example if you had a 50 50
mixture you would see
a shape of observance that looks like
this green scan
and so immediately you can understand
that
by just looking at what the shape is we
can tell how much of
each of these molecules is in there and
that's the principle of
multi-wavelengths
now you can do this not just by eye but
also mathematically
and then you can separate out these two
components
by deconvoluting the basis spectra from
these mixture spectra and you can define
how much of the red and how much of the
purple
as in any one of these so
how well that process works is
determined by this equation
which essentially tells you the angle
between the two vectors
that we're looking at one being the bsa
and the other one being the dna
so if you if you make the dot product
between the absorbance spectrum of dna
and the absorbance spectrum of bsa
and you divided by the product of the
magnitudes of each vector and then take
the inverse cosine you get this
angle here and this angle is zero
if the two vectors are linearly
dependent
meaning they um are essentially
identical
maybe just two scans at different
concentrations of the same thing
that would be zero this angle but if you
had two peaks that were completely
separated these ones are overlapping as
you can see but if they were completely
separated like let's say one at
500 nanometers and one at 200 nanometers
and there would be baseline separated
then this angle would be 90 degrees or
close to 90 degrees
meaning it's perfectly orthogonal the
closer this angle gets to 90 degrees the
easier it is
to separate out these components and get
these ratios correct
okay and this equation will tell us how
well they're separable
so our job is then to pick each one of
these radial positions
in each scan and decompose them
and this can be done with this method
called nnls
which basically finds the amplitude for
each one of these
spectral signatures here in this case
dna and bsa
and when we take these amplitudes for
every radial point
and every scan we can reconstruct the
original
experiment but with
a complete optical separation between
dna and bsa
so here we record the amplitude of bsa
and here we record the amplitude of dna
and these numbers are obtained by
fitting
a wavelength scan that we get here at
each radial position
so of course there's a lot of points to
calculate and then of course there are
many scans
and so for each scan we perform this
procedure
and we obtain these two two-dimensional
data sets now
and um
this process can be done all numerically
and you'll get all your
answers if these absorbance profiles
here
are actually in molar extinction
coefficients then the concentrations
here
will be in molar units so
then you can compare molar quantities
directly from your multi-wavelength
experiment
so just to show you what the experiments
looked like for these various mixtures
that were
um shown the observance spectra for
before
you can see that if you have 100 dna and
no
bsa then you essentially get a baseline
signal here
and you get a fairly large contribution
from your dna
and here is 80 20 you know 50 50 and so
forth
until we get to zero percent dna and 100
psa
now all the signal is blue and none of
the signal is red
so as you can see by looking at
different mixtures we can then
uh uniquely identify how much of each
species is present
and when you do the complete analysis
for anisotropy and molar mass or
sedation coefficient
you will get a baseline separation of
the dna contribution and the protein
contribution
so bsa is a molecule that forms a
monomer a diameter and a timer
and you can see those very clearly
separated here
and they're all fairly globular
molecules so they don't have a very high
uh ns entropy but the dna which is a
long linear
uh molecule these are double-stranded
dna fragments there's a 12 base per
fragment a 208 base per fragment
and a 28 11 base pair fragment so this
one is
um has a much higher anaesotropy because
it's very extended
very long molecule this one is somewhere
in the middle here at around three
and then we also see these things up
here so these
are uh somewhat ill-defined
pieces of dna which are either uncut
plasmids or
catamas or they could also be pieces of
chromosomal
uh dna that's all super cold and twisted
together
and therefore appears more or less on
spherical
so by being able to distinguish
dna and protein merely by their colors
here
we can then totally be sure that this
particle right here is not some
aggregate of the protein
but some sort of an aggregate of dna
so um you get a very clear separation
between these species and even those
that are very close together in s
are very clearly separated and not just
in color but also by anisotropy
they're very different nsr to be so we
can figure this out
if you do the same experiment with a
single wavelength
mode in the old proteome lab xla um
this is the type of picture you get
there so you see you have much less
resolution
and a lot more noise and it's really
hard to tell which one is which
and you can't be very definitive about
it here's your
um differential as value distribution
all these peaks are basically running
together while over here they're
completely baseline separated from each
other
one of them is red one of them is blue
this is dna this is bsa
so you can immediately appreciate the
wealth of information that we can get
by doing a multi-wavelength experiment
we can separate these two signals
completely
while in the old single wavelengths
method everything is sort of
bunched together and hard to tell which
is which
so the multi-wavelength analysis is
supported by the ultrascan software is
developed in my group
and as you can imagine when you have
data sets uh rather than just one the
computational requirements go up
and that is the challenge for the
analysis software
so by having this increased data density
um we have now data sets are much larger
because multiple wavelengths need to be
fitted simultaneously
um on the optima auc you have
approximately 1400 data points if you
measure the entire length of the cell
about 1.4 centimeters with 10 micron
resolution gives you about 1400 data
points
and then if you use the beckman software
you can collect 20 wavelengths
in one experiment uh with ultrascan you
can get up to 100
um in the optima auc although that takes
quite a while to get a single scan
but it is doable and uh in the curfew
optics where
all of the wavelengths are measured
simultaneously in parallel
you get 1024 wavelengths from a single
scan
so um the number of scans on
in the optima is restricted to 1500
scans per wavelength
and the data size then if you multiply
it all together uh
1400 points per radius
times uh times 100
wavelengths times 1500 data points
on or scans i should say
uh times four bytes per point we're
getting close to
84 um or 0.84 gigabytes just for the
for the single data set right uh
in the optima auc is experiments
where you have it collected in binary
format in the open auc ultra scan
data format so uh if you do this in an
ascii format like the
legacy software packages use it'll be
a huge multiple of that in terms of size
so
on but in the opening you see ultra scan
data format everything is binary which
compresses the data down significantly
the optima auc
data also require a time synchronization
step
because of course all wavelengths are
acquired sequentially
so they're not collected at the same
time and therefore
it would be difficult to get your
wavelength scan since you can't really
align them
everyone every scan every wavelength
scan was required at a different time
so ultrascan will interpolate the to the
the data back
by doing a 2dsa model of this and then
creating a synchronous time grid where
you can recreate
the wavelengths domain so you can
actually obtain the wavelengths out of
these data
this step is not required if you use the
curve and optics
and which can of course get everything
at the same time
so that's a big benefit there
so ultra scan then to analyze all of
these data uses a um
a parallel analysis platform
on where data is stored in mysql
database
on a limb server on there is an
infrastructure
available in the us and in europe on in
the us is provided by exceed and in
europe at price
that provide high performance computing
cluster where all of this information
can be analyzed in parallel
on big supercomputers and
there is a grid middleware that brokers
all the requests the different
supercomputers
uh that is called the arvata
and that's part of the system um for
users that
do not want to use these academic
environments uh
where they have to move the data outside
of the uh
on four walls we also offer an ultra
scan and a box high-end server
where all of these items are basically
in one big server
uh combined that can be directly hooked
up to your optima
in your own uh company uh corporate
environment and keep your data all saved
there
so that's another option for doing this
so we also have to talk about
experimental design considerations
for the optima auc as i already
mentioned the data are collected
sequentially of all wavelengths
the scanning speed is dependent on the
rotor speed and should be optimized to
achieve
perfect synchronization with the
flashlight flashing rate timing
so when the rotor hole comes by you want
to be able to flash
at certain speeds especially the slower
speeds
a change in just 100 rpm can actually
double the scanning speed because
instead of getting a
the window directly below the lamp
um the rotor has moved just a little bit
too far
and you have to wait a whole another
revolution of the rotor before you can
flash again
so that will make it almost twice as
long
for the uh for the scanning speed so
by uh judiciously picking the right
rotor speed you can optimize this
and then get very close to 15 seconds
per scan per cell and
that means it scan both the a and the b
channel which is about seven and a half
seconds per channel
and uh we measured all of that and then
ultra scan
this is all pre-programmed so you can
see how much speed you get
or scanning speed you get for each rpms
that you pick
so you pick the speed and it'll tell you
how long it will take to scan
the cell so by picking a motor speed
then that is maybe 100 rpm slower
you can then optimize your design and
maximize the number of scans that you
can get
on out of the machine secondly you
should always scan two samples if you
recall
the cell has two channels so you might
as well put two samples in it
because you can't tell it to just scan
channel a or channel b
it will always scan both channels so
regardless you might as well take
advantage of that
by putting a second sample in there but
um all data in the optima are acquired
in intensity mode
and you should not request observance
data because that will degrade the
quality of your data
due to the noise vector convolution you
get noise from the reference and you get
noise from your sample and adding them
together will
essentially give you a square root of
two increase in stochastic noise very
undesirable and so um
you want to want to avoid that you know
otherwise you get 1.4 times
more of the noise um and
secondly of course it preempts the use
of the second channel for another sample
because you
would have to put buffer into it
ultrascan will calculate the baseline
that you get from your buffer so you
don't even need to
measure it it can be calculated
um you should only measure a single cell
if you have a lot of wavelengths to scan
this way you can maximize all of the
scans and focus them just on that cell
rather than on measuring multiple scans
and having to wait until
multiple cells and having to wait and
all of them are finished
so maximize the number of scans that you
can obtain for
for each wavelengths
if the sample sediments very rapidly you
may have to reduce the rotor speed than
what you would use in a single
wavelength experiment just so you have
enough time so
all the all of the scans can be
collected before the sample is pelleted
you should also carefully match the
concentrations that you measure
and the wavelengths that you collect to
avoid exceeding the dynamic range of
your detector
or wavelengths so depending on the
wavelengths that you use the dynamic
range extends from about
0.05 od to about 1.54 d
um it could be less at a wavelength
where you have less intensity
and the optimal signal to noise is
typically around somewhere around
obtained somewhere around 0.60 d
so now let's look at some uh experiments
that
were actually done with
multi-wavelengths
this paper uh came out in 2016 i believe
and it described the interaction of
west nile virus rna um with
a host protein called tr a human t
cell restricted intercellular antigen
one related protein
which causes infectivity and the
questions were what is the binding
strength and why does it outcompete
cellular rna
and as you can see here on the
uh itc signal was not very nice and
it just never really came back to
baseline even at a six smaller ratio
so that that was when this group at
georgia state university from marcus
gelman and
margot and the postdoc jin zhang
um asked us to help them with this and
henwood and joel are in in
and constance ran the experiments and
reanalyzed it
so we ran a multi-wavelength experiment
and we decomposed
into the signal of the protein the rna
and also the buffer which did absorb it
didn't sediment so you
just get baseline observance but the
signal nevertheless needs to be
deconvoluted out as well so here's your
rna signal and here's your protein
signal
and now i'm sorry this is the the rna
signal is in blue and the protein in red
and when you measure the two molecules
by themselves you get
just boring single peaks meaning there
are
no dimers or anything like that they're
just single components which there's a
little bit of degradation here is the
rna
but when you mix them together you get a
shift in s and you get this really broad
boundary here
and you get about a two to one ratio of
the protein signal over the uh
rna signal and so the question is what
is this why are there so
why is this so broad this peak and it
turns out this is a reaction boundary
there are several association states and
you see sort of the weight average of
all of them and as you increase
the protein concentration in this case
we're we're measuring three to one and
here we measure six to one
uh you get a further shift to the right
and the
peak becomes somewhat more narrow and
also what you see is you see a change of
the ratio of protein to rna
going to about four to one and if you
increase it even further and add
tenfold the amount of protein then
rna you stay with this peak it shifts a
little bit further to the right it goes
from about 7.9 to about 8.6
and you get a very narrow peak again
with a 4 to 1
ratio but you also see that there's
material piling up over here
which is your free protein that is not
bound so all the rna is consumed
but there's excess protein in here and
that can't bind to anything
so it just makes a another peak just
like if you ran it by itself
so that kind of shows you what happens
in an association
so here we clearly have co-sedimenting
species
and that form a complex otherwise they
wouldn't all be sedimenting at the same
position
and you can look at this in this format
here and you can integrate the peaks
and you get a calculation for the molar
mass
knowing what the ratio is 4 to 1 you can
then also calculate a partial specific
volume
and with this calculated specific volume
you can then get a molar mass
and from that molar mass you can then
derive the ratio
as well if we just have the absorbance
ratio
which is one to four we don't really
know if it's two to eight or
four to sixteen or something like that
um
until we do the hydrodynamics so you
also need the hydrodynamics and in this
case
it turns out we get molar mass of about
152 000.
the theoretical molar mass of a one two
four complex is 151
285 so this is very close
so there's no way this is anything else
but a one two four
it's definitely not a two to eight and
for sure not a 16
or a four to 16 or something like that
so it would have to be a one to four so
this is what you get out of this
you get a very un ambiguous
calculation of your molar ratio of this
complex and how big it is
the next experiment that i want to tell
you was done by chris horne
and on wren dobson's lab at the
university of
canterbury in new zealand uh he actually
came to visit us here in lethbridge
and brought his samples with them and
ran it on the optima
and what he has is this transcriptional
regulator called nan r from e coli
that binds a dna fragment here
and this uh
binding was what he was studying of this
nanr to the dna
so here um he started out doing some
binding assays on gel shift assays
by adding one more of the protein to
this dna template
and you notice how he gets additional
species formed here
that are complexes of the protein
together with his dna
doing a multi-wavelength experiment he
measured the molar extinction
coefficient of the dna and the molar
extinction coefficient of the protein
at a wavelengths range starting at 220
going up to about 320.
and um
then he was trying to obtain evidence
for
um number one is this monomeric or
dimeric as it binds
and then how many of these copies bind
to these recognition sites that are
on this dna template doing the
experiment again
by themselves each sample by itself he
gets the dna here
um sedimenting around 2.8 and the
uh the protein sedimenting around 3.9
uh nice homogeneous single peaks but
when they're mixed together
you see a shift occur and both the rna
and the protein on absorb in a molar
ratio here
shown on and the s values shift
so we have a complex form we have free
protein and free dna
and then we have complexes that again
make
a broad reaction boundary as multiple
proteins bind to
this dna template when you increase the
protein concentration
you get you lose the
one one uh one to one and you only see
the two
and the three two uh one uh binding
complex here
and finally at very high concentration
you saturate out
all the dna that's there just like we
did in the west nile
virus experiment and you get a
ratio that indicates that six
monomers bind to one dna template
and this was a 10 to one mixture so we
ended up getting some excess
free protein forms over here
so that's another um way of how you can
analyze these somewhat complex systems
and get very
high resolution information the next
example
um is to show you how you could
introduce spectral variety by fusing
your protein to
various fluorescent proteins which now
come in all kinds of colors as you can
see over here
and um when you calculate the separation
between
these colors uh you get very large
uh angles here uh so for for your
reference a protein and a dna molecule
would be
closer to maybe 35 these are almost
twice as big
and so we get good separation between
these um
if you just pick the um
orthogonal regions you can squeeze this
even higher this angle
and get even better separation and so
what we did
is take two of these proteins mix them
together
different ratios and then ask the
questions how well can we recover those
ratios
very similar with the dna and the bsa
experiment
and as you can see you know here's the
one to one we get pretty much the same
height
uh here's a one two three so we get
three times higher peak for that one
here's a five to one so we have a five
times higher peak of this one versus
that one
so um what that tells you is that
if you were to fuse your protein that is
interacting with another protein
was a different on fluorophore or
fluorescent protein in this case
the absorbance that you get from these
fluorescent proteins can then be used to
introduce the spectral variety that
helps you
differentiate the interactions of these
molecules
here's another example of where we mix
three of them together
three different ones and the twist here
is is that
two of them were added at exactly the
same amount
and they also have exactly the same size
this one here which is
on the the ultramarine fluorescent
protein
it behaves as a constituent dimer so it
always sediments faster
than the monomeric fluorescent proteins
all the fluorescent proteins are
essentially the same molar mass
so you get the same peak and if you mix
them at the same ratio you also get the
same height of these
and uh which basically tells you that
that all of these species even if they
have exactly the same s
value can be 100 resolved
because of their spectrum that all these
experiments were done on the optima
and so you can get very very clean
results on
separating out exactly which component
is which even if they have the same
hydrodynamics
so let's apply this to some experiments
on
so here we have um a molecule called
cytochrome c
which contains a heme group so that
provides it um in the presence of
um zinc actually fluorescence but it
also
emits or it absorbs in the visible so
cytochrome c is sort of reddish and
absorbs at about 4 10.
so um what we've done here is
try to figure out if there is an
interaction
with cardiolipin between cytochrome c
with cytochrome c and so we made uh
cardiolipin membranes by embedding them
in nanodisks
and if you measure cytochrome by itself
it's a small molecule it's sediments
like this blue curve right here
the nano does have a belt protein apoe
which sort of makes a circle and then
allows it to
reconstitute lipids in the middle and
making this nice disc
and this uh shape of course is bigger
than molar mass so it settlements faster
and there's some heterogeneity here
as shown in the green curve so the green
curve was measured just
at 280 uh looking for the
tryptophans here in this apoe belt
protein
now when you put the cytochrome c in
there you can see
that the cytochrome c all of a sudden
sediments are much faster
this is cytochrome c a limited amount of
but there's some excess of cytochrome c
added so we have some free cytochrome c
that's not binding
but you can very clearly see that this
material here actually binds
and there may actually be more than one
cytochrome c bound to this nanodisc
here so you can measure the binding of
your protein to a lipid
which i think is pretty cool here's an
uh even more cool experiment if you look
at cytochrome c
in the oxidized or reduced form
you can see that they have very
different spectra okay so the blue is a
reduced form and the red is the oxidized
form
so in the reduced form you get this very
characteristic oops let me just go back
characteristic double peak here around
between 500 and 550 nanometers
so just using these uh regions here that
are very different
we can then make a measurement
on off and follow the cytochrome c
that's oxidized
and follow the cytochrome c that's
reduced and lo and behold they behave
differently when they bind to the
cardiolipin
nanodisc it turns out that when
um what we're doing is probing the
apoptosis that's triggered by cytochrome
c
so the idea would be that cytochrome c
might degrade the
um uh the uh the nanodisc
or the the membrane at least so what's
happening
is um that if we look at the oxidized
form
we get this very broad boundary
showing essentially many different sizes
of lipids
that are bound so this would suggest
that maybe the oxidized form
causes um a uh
degradation of the membrane and then
causes this heterogeneity
however the reduced form doesn't seem to
have that it's very very homogeneous
and it just shows the nanodisc and the
cytochrome c bound to the narrative but
it doesn't do anything
stays intact so the oxidized and the
reduced form behave very differently
and have a very different profile
something you can learn by doing a
multi-wavelength analysis
another way you can utilize
multi-wavelengths is by
following on the loading of
nanoparticles with
for example rna if you look at the rna
spectrum
it doesn't absorb at all until you get
to about 260 you get a peak there
nano discs or i should say um lipid my
cells
and um in this case lipid nanoparticles
um they don't absorb but they give you a
pseudo observance from the light
scattering that they
create which increases with decreasing
wavelengths
and using that signature and then
looking at a narrative that's felt
you get a signature of the
um of this deviation here where the rna
actually absorbs so these lipid
nanoparticles have
rna in it and that's shown in blue
if you analyze this in the
multi-wavelengths experiment you can
then get
um a separation of particles based on
their density
because they're sediment with different
rates once they contain some
rna and you can then
follow that um and look at the
signatures that you get from the
spectral resolution and find out that
they indeed contain rna
that same principle also works with aav
or other
viral vectors which are basically
composed of protein
and a nucleic acid and then you can
measure how much nucleic acid is in
there by using that same principle
and the last example that i'm going to
show you here is
on that where you go the other way what
if you don't know what the observant
spectrum is
and you have a mixture of things that
absorb at different wavelengths but
you really don't know what these
components are so what you see here on
the left
is essentially a sedimentation profile
that shows you
where it's absorbing so we obtain
an absorbance on profile from the
materials that we separate out
hydrodynamically
so we're going basically in the reverse
and
what you see here is a sample that was
extracted out of all seeds
and all seeds this is a big business
here in alberta
uh like rapeseed and canola and so forth
they contain polyphenols which are small
molecules that are
absorbed in the visible and so you see
these small molecules here around 1s
these are the polyphenols and the
question here was
what proteins do we have and are they
bound to polyphenols
and as you can see very clearly there's
very little of any
polyphenol bond to this protein and same
here
there's another protein there's less of
it there are sediments about 2s
but it's also not bound to the
polyphenols which sediment
separately as the spectrum shows
here's one where you have a protein and
dna mixture use a
characteristic protein sedimenting at
about 5s
and here's a dna that
sediments at about 12 s and
so they are very different spect spectra
and so you can see that here
by just looking at the spectral
signature of the sedimentation profile
so this is another thing you can do here
now um i want to summarize
my talk uh by giving you an overview of
the benefits that we get from
multi-wavelengths experiments so instead
of a single wavelengths now
many wavelengths can be collected you
can resolve multiple chromophores that
may be present
in a mixture and you can then therefore
characterize much more complex mixtures
by either decomposing the
the different common forests that are in
there or showing the sedimentation
profile
and showing basically what the
absorbance profile
is and the increased data density from
multiple
wavelengths results in a better signal
to noise ratio as we saw with the dna
and the bsa mixture
where we get very clean signal and not
all the scattered data from the xla
so you get because you measure so much
more data you get higher
signal to noise ratio um therefore you
can
uh answer new and exciting questions you
can invest
make new investigations that weren't
possible before
uh so this is very exciting and with the
new hardware that we have from beckmann
that optima auc
uh you have this whole thing available
commercially and you can
do it yourself and with the high
performance computing that you have
available through
ultrascan you can address these
multi-wavelength data challenges that we
have
and one direction multi-wavelength
applications
include protein nucleic acid
interactions proteins with fluorescent
protein fusions like for example gfp
or rfp or yfp and you can also use
fluorescent tags if there's enough
tag on there you get enough of an
extinction that you can follow that as
well
or you can use proteins which have
intrinsic chromophores
uh maybe in the visible range where they
wouldn't overlap with the uv
spectrum for example a heme does that
there could be others mixtures
containing small interacting molecules
like drugs for example
that may have a very strong absorbance
in the uv and that may be different from
protein absorbance so that could be
followed as well
you can study nanoparticle loading viral
vector loading
and the separation of spectrally
distinct solutes in mixtures
for composition identification
so um i'm at the end of my talk and i
just
would like to put in a quick plug for
the 25th international auc conference
which will take place july 11 through
16th
next year next summer here in lethbridge
um we will be hosting at uh please mark
your calendar and
follow this website right here auc
2021.uleth.ca
for any updates and i want to thank you
for your attention if you have any
questions that we can't answer here
today
feel free to send them to my personal
email dml gmail.com
and i would also like to credit some of
my collaborators
um in my group emory brooks gary gorbad
kip j and alexis savalia have
done the programming on the ultrascan
software
my daughter aisha was involved in the
analysis
of the bsa and dna mixtures
amy runs our lab here and help with all
the other experiments that you saw if
she didn't do them herself
as does christiana and marielle
carmen on is uh
was postdoc in my lab and worked on the
cytochrome c
sample on also together with sandy ross
and bruce bola from the university of
montana
wyoming chow at the university of texas
in san antonio
um helped us with the finite element
solutions and
inward curve and joe pearson ing and car
gudak
developed the multi-wavelengths detector
of the first generation the curfew
optics um that can acquire all the data
all at once
uh at georgia state university the group
of uh marcus garman and michael brink
uh brenton were involved with the west
nile virus study
and the nr um
protein dna interaction was done by
chris horn and renwick adoptions lab at
the university of canterbury
and at the university of british
columbia we're working together with
peter collis angelico connie
and dominic ritzigman to
study the lipid nanoparticles and i want
to also thank eric from segrent from
beckmann culture engineering
who helped us with the data acquisition
uh
integration of ultrascan on the optima
we have funding from the national
science foundation the nih
uh tera grid exceed for the high
performance computing allocations
um canada foundation for innovation
uh the national science and engineering
research council in canada
alberta innovates and the canadian
institute for health research so we want
to appreciate all
we i want to thank all of those and
appreciate their support
and finally i'd like to show a
disclaimer page that pikmin asked me to
show
and thank you again for your interest
and
to see you again sometime
thank you dr tembler for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for all right so let's get started our
first question
is how many wavelengths can you acquire
with the optima auc and what limitations
exist
so uh the number of wavelengths that you
can acquire
depends on which software you use
if you use the beckman software on you
can collect 20 wavelengths
per channel with the
ultrascan software you can go up to 100
however there are limitations and the
limitations are primarily dictated by
the
by the scanning speed with which you can
collect the data
since all wavelengths are collected
sequentially you need to allow for
time to collect all of the wavelengths
that you want to
measure and the more wavelengths you
collect the longer it will take
per scan so if you
were to measure 100 wavelengths it would
really take a long time
to get to the second scan because you
have to scan
all the 100 wavelengths for for the
first scan
and then the second scan and so forth so
the number of scans that you will get
for each individual wavelengths will
decrease and there's another limitation
which is that for each wavelength that
you want to collect
on the instrument has to do
a calibration at the beginning of the
run
which takes about a minute per
wavelength so you can
maybe not that long but it'll take a
certain amount of time which will delay
the start of the scanning
so um it is it depends on the
experimental conditions how slow you can
run
and how much resolution you need from
your experiment
in order to decide how many wavelengths
are practical to be collected on the
optima
thank you okay let's go on to the next
question dr tumblr
uh here goes i'm studying a protein plus
small molecule system
i have recorded one experiment with
absorbance data acquired at 280
nanometers
and another experiment with absorbance
data acquired at 490 nanometers
which is my small molecule absorption
maximum peak
now can i acquire these two independent
experiments
uh sorry can i combine these two
independent experiments
for multi-wavelength analysis
yes in principle that's perfectly
adequate to do that
the question is whether it's sufficient
to
get a separation and that depends on the
spectrum
of the protein or the molecule and
and the other interacting component the
small molecule
and if they don't have any overlaps or
if the um
resolution or i should say the
separation of the spectra is sufficient
as described in my talk
um then this will work otherwise you
will have to add additional wavelengths
to make the
separation more distinct so it really
depends on the angle
between the two two spectra that you
have so
it should be as large as possible
so an extension of that question is the
next one
is there any way that i can incorporate
the interference data which i've
acquired at the same time as a 260
as well as a 280 nanometer absorbance
experiment as in can i use the intensity
data set
as a pseudo wavelength data set and then
incorporate it into the multi-wavelength
analysis
no not really um the problem with that
is is that
you don't really know what the
refractive index is of every species in
your mixture
and what you see is essentially a
collection of all of the
refractive indices um in the
in the mixture at every point in the in
the cell
and since there is no way to
optically deconvolute them and assign
like let's say molar concentrations to
them
um this is an unreliable way of adding
information
and it's it's really not a good way to
to perform your multi-wavelength
experiment
okay so as an extension of that question
dr daimler again
uh since each component has to be
fingerprinted
via a uv-vis spectrophotometer in order
to do really good multi-wavelength
analysis
supposing we had a way to specifically
say that we have
components x y and z in our
sample which have the refractive indexes
of r1
r2 and r3 uh which are recorded
independently not
in the auc instrument would that help
um it's it's not really
the way the software is designed to be
able to uh
incorporate that data that is not what
we're trying to do here
we're just uh looking at the observance
specter for which we have
precise molar on molar descriptions
for each of the species
at every wavelength that is being
measured if we had that for the
for the refractive indices of all of the
species
um maybe there is a way to include that
but
the software is not designed to handle
that
all right there's one more question we
have time for and it
is this is there a trade-off between
spectral angle
and the number of wavelengths to give a
good result
well in general the larger the angle the
better
and it just depends on how much
resolution
and how much separation you really
expect to uh
to have and you need in order to
conclusively decide what
species the spectrum should be assigned
to or the concentration should be
assigned to
so the more species you include uh the
more wave
the more species with different spectra
you're trying to
deconvolute from your from your system
the more
separation you should have if you just
have two species like protein and dna
you can go to fairly low angles and
still get satisfactory results
so in general what you want to do is
look for those regions in the spectrum
where you get the most difference and
then pick those wavelengths
and include those and then use that
angle calculator and ultra scan to
figure out
how much difference you can get from
different combinations of wavelengths
and then just simply pick the one with
the smallest number and the
smallest number of wavelengths and the
largest uh degree of separation and
those will be the best ones to use
thank you unfortunately it seems that we
have
run out of time so i want to remind our
audience
that the questions we were unable to
answer today and those that will be
coming in to us during the on-demand
period that the presentation will be
available on lab roots
will all be answered by dr tumbler and
sent to you
at the email address you provided at the
time of registration
dr dimbler do you have any final
comments for our audience
well i'd just like to say that we feel
that multi-wavelength is a
an exciting new toolbox for auc and
uh that there will likely be many more
uh
important applications that can be
solved with it and
so i'd like you to think about how you
might be able to incorporate it into
your own uh
research as well and if you have any
questions feel free to contact me
thank you mr tumbler so before we before
we wrap up i'd like to thank the
audience today for joining us
and for their amazing questions uh again
we will try to get to all of the
questions that you've submitted
via the question box and answer you
directly
to the email address that you used at
the time of registration and we want to
thank dr daimler again
for his time today and for his many many
contributions to auc research and we'd
also like to extend our thanks to labruz
as well as our sponsor beckman cultural
life sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thank you for joining
us again
goodbye have a nice day